allerdings wieder eure malen fahne und
willkommen zum sommer noch nummer 4 der
erste punkt auf unserer liste
die redaktion hat beschlossen dass das
instagram den streifen ist und dies
rausnehmen und vorschläge werden dankend
angenommen
moment ich höre gerade das ist die
letzte folge sommer es ist zu kalt und
die ferien sind schon okay gut ja und
somit ist das die letzte folge
sommerloch sparst du mir mal dass die
tragische fall los aktuelle sache nun zu
denen ich etwas sagen will auch dann
keinen interessiert dieses mal habe ich
leider nichts zu sagen aber dann macht
ihr das einfach in den kommentaren
geschichten aus der youtube welt die
erste geschichte ist eigentlich meine
eigene denn ich habe euch vor zwei
wochen meine letzte zigarette
präsentiert und da so viele nachgefragt
haben will ich euch jetzt einfach nur
sagen ja ich bin seit zwei wochen
rauchfrei aber ich habe eigentlich so
viel zu dem thema zu sagen und möchte
eigentlich also das würde jetzt hier den
rahmen sprengen deswegen mache ich noch
ein eigenes video dazu und wir machen
mit dem nächsten thema weiter genauso
viele haben jetzt schon langsam
mitbekommen dass sich umgezogen bin also
es ist auch nicht schwer zu erkennen
an den hintergrund noch nie gesehen hat
kann man sich da schon viele angefragt
ob ich vielleicht mitmachen kann habe
ich euch das mut zu zeigen kann
und ja also ich würde gerne zu machen
ich gucke mir das bei anderen volk gerne
an ich weiß nicht warum das ist ein
bisschen wie diese sendung mieten kaufen
wohnen oder es gab früher noch seine
sendung irgendwie unsere erste
gemeinsame wohnung da mir das auch mal
gemacht und hier einsatz in vier wänden
wer sich noch an diese schmuckstücke
erinnern kann und ja kann nicht gerne
machen sonne wolken sonne wollte ich
kann mir nicht mal ein studio leisten
die voting phase von tubes 2 ist jetzt
ganz vorbei ist gibt nichts mehr zu
entscheiden denke ich also eine sache
vorweg unter die 20 youtube an warnten
gefährden 8 versteht mich nicht falsch
ich kenne viele von ihnen auch
persönlich und mag dir auch richtig
gerne nur wo ist die vielfalt unter den
kommentaren habe ich diese liste vom 30
august gefunden womit glaube ich fest
steht dass es sieben minecraft let's
play 3 andersartige youtuber sein werden
obwohl melina setzt auf nichts player
dünn und mit helm dorfplatz ins der
neuen gamer viel spaß julien benneteau
studien mach uns stolz was ist denn
eigentlich nicht meine außer asiate nein
ich meinte unterhaltung oder so ich sehe
mich ja mal ein unterhaltung von studien
bestimmt auch unterhaltung sport
unterhaltung
tja da victory ich konnte in den
kommentaren auch lesen dass nicht nur
ich von der auswahl der youtuber
irritiert war aber wer weiß vielleicht
kannst du ja einfach die minecraft welt
nehmen und die charaktere darauf setzen
ich meine es wird einiges einfacher
machen kommen wir nun zum wetter das
richtig heiße wetter ist jetzt vorbei
und jetzt kommen diese waren kalten
tagen morgens aufstehst es richtig kalt
und es ist mittags so eklig war
längst mich auszuziehen und der
zwiebellook ist in diesen tagen sehr
lieb und passt auch liebes oktoberfest
in münchen wird am freitag nicht ganz so
schön das wetter wurden präsentiert von
platzenden tor anziehen
wer von euch kommt er nach münchen oder
fährt in dieser zum oktoberfest
ich war noch nie da und ich glaube es
ist ein unding noch nie dagewesen zu
sein
was sagt ihre so und bevor wir zur
twitter frage kommen
hab einen kleinen anschlag auf euch vor
und zwar habe ich ja in den kommentaren
einmal lesen können dass ihr das
sommerloch auch ganz gerne mögen so wie
ich deshalb geht das auch mal auch in
die nächste runde
mit einem neuen namen und auch
vielleicht anderen rubriken wenn es
möglich ist ich habe meine gehirnzellen
angekurbelt und kam auf übergangsjacke
nasser hose und glied wetter und wenn
euch eins davon gefällt dann schreibt es
mir auch in die kommentare
oder ist eine ganz andere super idee für
neuen titel und wenn euch wirklich neue
rubriken einfallen also kommentare
kommentieren wenn euch das jetzt so in
dieser form gefallen würde oder ganz
andere sachen
dann schreibt und jetzt gibt es
natürlich wie twitter
ich habe euch vor ewigkeiten auf twitter
gefragt wenn ihr sofort eine maschine
erfinden könnte wie würde sie heißen und
welche funktionen ist okay der ist
schwer
der anti bullshit die nato würde den
menschen jeglichen unsinn aus dem kopf
prügeln die bringen mich zum anfang der
sommerferien maschine wie wäre es mit
einer zeitmaschine zeitmaschine und die
würde meine wohnung putzen würde immer
meine hausarbeiten erledigen er zwei
tage und laien wieder zusammenbringen
was du meinst geld teleport ii und wie
der name schon sagt eine teleportation
maschine
ich bin telepathie die lustige
teleportation snaschel schreiberin
werden singles im kopf kommt alles
verkauf mit meinen jingles name roboter
sieht aus wie gut kann sich in dich
verwandeln du kannst ihn auf ein
bestimmtes programm einstellen was er
machen soll denkt noch jemand an pornos
wo der prostitution herein so viel geld
verdienen das war ein roboter hannes
rehm egal gibt es mir maschine wenn man
auf dem bett liegt und zum beispiel sein
handy vergessen hat prägt es mir ja das
ist super praktisch aber kleiner tipp
dafür hat man einen freund für gibt es
mehr dinge
anderes weiterhin freie 1000 und erkannt
backen braten man kann doch nicht aber
sachen umbenennen und dann so tun als ob
eine neue erfindung wäre okay den gay
die natur für unendlich geld oder an den
welpen ator unendlich behalten
ich glaube ich will den welpen nato geht
mach dich nicht so glücklich aber welten
die teams der stuhl vergolder macht hat
aus stuhlgang gold wie der name schon
sagt das war die letzte folge sommerloch
dann geht irgendwann weiter bis dann
tschüss